das Chaos an den Flughäfen zu
Ferienbeginn ist ein Sinnbild geworden
für den Mangel an Personal der
inzwischen aber fast überall herrscht in
der Pflege in der Gastronomie in den
Kitas und das ist nur ein Problem vor
dem Wirtschaft und Verbraucher
zusammenstehen denn zusätzlich machen
die hohe Inflation und die steigenden
Energiekosten Sorgen der Finanzminister
stimmt auf Entbehrungen ein der
Bundeskanzler will einmal Geld verteilen
die Industrie fordert die 42 Stunden
Woche und Arbeitskräfte aus der Türkei
die sollen jetzt unsere Koffer schleppen
ist das nur der Anfang einer langen
Talfahrt auf was müssen sich die Bürger
einstellen Preisschock und
Personalmangel droht die
Wirtschaftskrise unser Thema in der
phönix-runde
[Musik]
guten Abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
Berlin ich darf hier meine Gäste
vorstellen ich begrüße herzlich Ulrike
Kostka sie ist Direktorin des
Caritasverbandes für das Erzbistum
Berlin hat also viele Pflegekräfte auch
unter sich und auch Krankenhäuser und
herzlich willkommen dr Hans-jürgen Völs
Chef Volkswirt beim Bundesverband für
mittelständische Wirtschaft herzlich
willkommen Daniel goffart Chefreporter
der Wirtschaftswoche und zugeschaltet
ist uns Hannes Walter von der SPD er ist
stellvertretender Vorsitzender des
Ausschusses für Wirtschaft und Klima des
Bundestags ein Wahlkreis ist in
Brandenburg in der Lausitz Frau Kostka
möchte ich gerne mit ihnen beginnen wenn
man jetzt sagt viele merken die Preise
steigen irgendwie funktioniert es auf
vielen Ebenen nicht Personalmangel all
das wo merken sie es konkret das ist
gerade nicht so rund läuft also wir
merken es unter anderem daran dass die
Tafeln ein unheimlichen Zulauf haben
dass die Menschen einfach Nöte haben
weil sie die steigenden Preise einfach
nicht bezahlen können da merken wir es
und wir merken natürlich auch dass sich
viele Wohnung machen das ist ein
Riesenthema das gilt auch für unsere
MitarbeiterInnen dass sie sich fragen
wie das so weitergeht also so eine
allgemeine Verunsicherung das sind
eigentlich die beiden Faktoren die es
jetzt am meisten abbilden und beim
Personalmangel beim Personalmangel da
spüren wir natürlich auch die Folgen von
Corona also das heißt viele Leute sind
jetzt erschöpft viele
sind auch krank noch weil gerade im
Kita-Bereich in der Pflege die haben
unheimlich tolle Arbeit geleistet aber
jetzt spürt man diese Erschöpfung und
manche fragen sich natürlich auch ob sie
weitermachen wobei wir auch erleben dass
unheimlich viel das auch machen wollen
aber es ist schon zu beobachten dass der
Fachkräftemangel zunimmt Herr Völz wenn
man auf die Unternehmen schaut wo sehen
sie da die Probleme und die Sorgen wo
merken sie dass sich da gerade was
ändert ja was die Preise angeht ist
mittlerweile die Situation eingetreten
dass viele Unternehmen vor der Waage
stehen ob sie überhaupt noch produzieren
weil das nicht produzieren günstiger ist
als das Produzieren zu Preisen die sie
ja nicht konnten weitergeben können der
Materialmangel Lieferengpässe
Vorprodukte die nicht rechtzeitig kommen
all das sind zentrale Themen wohlgemerkt
auch den der Fachkräftemangel der sich
ja mittlerweile zu einem veritablen
Arbeitskräftemangel ausgeweitet hat es
wäre also für viel zu sagen das Projekt
nur noch ein einzelnen Bereichen
Fachkräfte sondern diese Arbeitskräfte
Mangel zieht sich durch alle Branchen
durch die gesamte Volkswirtschaft und er
wird sich weiter beschleunigen also auch
Sorgen oder mit sorgen blicken sie auf
den Herbst genau wie Frau Kostka
letztendlich auch die Hoffnung stirbt
zuletzt aber die Sorgen sind zurzeit
leider dominierend ja Herr Walter wenn
Sie das Hören einerseits aus der Sicht
von Pflege von Sozialverbänden auf der
anderen Seite von Unternehmen sie müssen
ja beiden da gerecht werden in der
Politik wie kann die SPD dafür sorgen
das höre ich gerade das Thema
Fachkräftemangel höre ich von allen
Seiten ich bin in meinem Wahlkreis
natürlich ganz viel unterwegs heute
gerade in der Kita da haben Fachkräfte
gefehlt bei Unternehmen fehlen
Fachkräfte die SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
hat das im Wahlprogramm
geschrieben und hat es auch in den
Koalitionsvertrag verhandelt wir
brauchen mehr Fachkräfte wir wollen eine
große fachkräfteoffensive mache gerade
im Bereich der Bildung der
Berufsausbildung ist das ganz wichtig
immer mehr Handwerkerinnen und
Handwerker fehlen da kommen große
Probleme und Herausforderungen auf uns
zu aber das wird ja dauern bevor sie das
Umsetzen das hilft ja im Moment nicht
wenn es am Flughafen nicht klappt
das stimmt und hier brauchen wir auch
gezielte Zuwanderung das sage ich ganz
offen
wir werden die Probleme also die
Probleme wenn er auch mittelfristig
nicht weniger und das haben wir aber auf
dem Schirm und wir arbeiten daran es
wird nicht leicht aber
es wird
wir sind dran wir sind dran sagt Herr
Walter wenn Sie das Hören also
einerseits die Einschätzungen jetzt
haben wir Politik Sozialverband
Unternehmen als jemand der das
beobachtet auch schon seit vielen Jahren
wo sagen sie wäre jetzt der Punkt oder
ist das jetzt ein Punkt wo man sagt da
ist im Moment eine wirkliche Veränderung
also man kann die wirkliche Veränderung
bei den Themen Fachkräftemangel bei dem
Thema Inflationsbekämpfung nicht sehen
die Inflation hat ja eine Ursache
jedenfalls zum kommt natürlich aus einer
Politik da Europäischen Zentralbank
heraus die über Jahre hinweg in den
Jahren wo es sehr gut gelaufen ist wo
wir auch wirklich exzellente
Zuwachsraten hatten
konjunkturaufschwünge in all diesen
Jahren hat die EZB eine Politik der
wundersamen Geldvermehrung betrieben und
irgendwann haben wir jetzt gemerkt das
funktioniert nicht mehr die Märkte
reagieren darauf die Zinsen steigen die
Inflation steigt zu den Problemen die
wir ohnehin noch haben Olaf Scholz hat
die zeitenwände ausgerufen das gilt
natürlich mit Blick auf die Bewaffnung
der Bundeswehr auf das auf die
militärischen Fragen wer braucht
natürlich auch eine Zeitenwende glaube
ich auch im ökonomischen Verständnis in
vielen Dingen könnte die aussehen oder
was wäre so ein Punkt wo sie sagen daran
würde man das merken na gut also der
erste Punkt ist glaube ich dass man eine
Angebotspolitik machen muss das heißt
man sollte versuchen den Unternehmen
entgegenzukommen es gibt ja auch die
Idee der Konzer Aktion die jetzt nächste
Woche Montag starten soll also indem man
versucht durch eine Einmalzahlung den
Beschäftigten Stück weit
entgegenzukommen den Leuten die
wahrscheinlich im Herbst Nachzahlungen
haben für ihre Gasrechnungen für
Wasserstrom für all die Dinge die jetzt
schon tanken müssen für viel Geld also
den durch eine Einmalzahlung ein
bisschen zu helfen und dafür so der
voraus gedacht Deal verzichten die
Gewerkschaften halt auf eine große
Lohnsteigerung das hätte den Vorteil
dass es nicht eine dauerhafte
Lohnerhöhung gibt sondern einmal Effekt
und das sozusagen die die Löhne nicht
steigen die Unternehmen die sich steigen
Löhne nicht mit Produkten weitergeben
müssen also diese Lohn Preisspirale Miss
zu stoppen ob das funktioniert letzter
Satz nur die Hälfte ist tarifgebunden
die Hälfte beschäftigt in Deutschland
die andere Hälfte wird möglicherweise
nicht davon profitieren insofern muss
man dauern Fragezeichen
von Unternehmer Seite wo könnte die
Politik Ihnen jetzt helfen zunächst
einmal zu dem Vorschlag ein mahlzeitung
das ist ein völlig untaugliches Mittel
es ist im Grunde genommen der zweite
Verstoß gegen den die Tarifautonomie im
Bundestagswahlkampf hat der damalige
Kanzlerkandidat Olaf Scholz die 12 Euro
propagiert und damit den Mindestlohn bis
12 Euro propagiert und dann ja nicht
unwesentlich auch Erfolg damit erzielt
unsere Auffassung ist die das diese
Punkte diskutiert werden müssen nur
zwischen Arbeitgebern Arbeitnehmern ohne
Einmischung des Staates Artikel 93
Grundgesetz Tarifautonomie und wenn die
das in Verhandlungen zu dem Ergebnis
kommen dass das ein angeeignetes Mittel
ist dann tritt der Effekt ein der gerade
beschrieben worden ist von der Koffer
aber darüber hinaus ist das wie ich
finde
kein guter Weg der beste Weg wäre
zum einen komme ich gerade auf das
Beispiel der Politik zurück die
Ampelkoalition hat beschlossen dass der
vom Agenda 2010 Fördern und Fordern
abgerückt wird das zukünftig das fordern
nicht keine Rolle mehr spielen soll zum
ersten Juli beschlossen gibt es keine
Sanktionen mehr wenn angebotene Arbeiten
nicht angenommen werden und das hat zu
Konsequenz dass 3,5 Millionen Hartz IV
Empfänger dem Arbeitsmarkt im Grunde
genommen Potenzial nicht mehr zur
Verfügung stehen weil der anreizarbeit
aufzunehmen einfach verschwindet finden
sie zu gering den Anreiz auf Arbeit
aufsetzen mal im nächsten Jahr auch noch
angedacht ist daraus ein bedingungsloses
nahezu bedingungsloses Bürgergeld zu
machen das wird also auf Dauer
festgeschrieben das Hartz IV Empfänger
der Anreiz des Forderns nicht mehr
existiert das heißt die befürchten dass
dadurch noch weniger Menschen eben
arbeiten dass der Personalmenge noch
größer als Vollkosten ich finde das ist
eine ziemliche Vereinfachung einer sehr
komplexen Situation sehr viele Menschen
die Hartz IV bekommen sind
Alleinerziehende sind Menschen die
multiple vermittl Hindernisse haben
natürlich gibt es auch Leute die sich
vielleicht
die arbeitsfähig werden unsere Erfahrung
sieht ganz anders aus also der
Arbeitsmarkt nimmt zurzeit jeden was
auch gut ist weil es dadurch auch
Chancen gibt für Menschen die sonst
vorher keine Möglichkeit hatten und also
sollten so eine Stigmatisierung die Sie
gerade gemacht haben halte ich einfach
ist nicht realistisch und bringt auch
nichts das entscheiden ist aus unserer
Sicht das natürlich auch Menschen die
die verschiedene Probleme haben auch von
Unternehmen auch aufgenommen werden wir
müssen den ganzen Niedriglohnsektor das
ist ein riesiges Problem dass wir viele
Menschen in prekära Beschäftigung haben
ab 1 Oktober haben wir 12 Euro
Mindestlohn trotzdem bei den steigenden
Preisen ist das noch nicht ausreichend
aber was wir ganz in dieser Debatte
gerade vernachlässigt haben dass von
solchen Maßnahmen wie am Montag
diskutiert wird zum Beispiel Menschen
mit kleinen Renten überhaupt nicht
profitieren also das heißt diese diese
Initiative
Aktion oder konzertierte Aktionen aber
es ist definitiv so dass in den ganzen
entlastungspaketen bislang Menschen mit
geringen Renten zum Beispiel überhaupt
nicht betrachtet wurden und wir erleben
wirklich eine permanent jede Woche
steigende Altersarmut und das ist eine
der Gruppen die unbedingt in den Fokus
kommen muss da ist das neun Euro Ticket
nicht aber das ist nur ein Baustein
unter vielen es gab heute die Forschung
des armutsberichtes Paritätischen
Wohlfahrtsverband der auch da sagt das
eben der 16,6 Prozent der Deutschen
Armut leben 13,8 Millionen Menschen dass
das auch 600.000 mehr sind als vor der
Pandemie Herr Walter wenn Sie das jetzt
hören Herr Völz sagt dass wir müssen
mehr fördern wir müssen da auch Druck
auf Hartz IV beziehe machen Frau kostker
widerspricht dem wo sie ihn sie sich da
wie kriegt man mehr Menschen in Arbeit
wieder wenn wir sagen wir haben
dreieinhalb Millionen Hartz IV Empfänger
also zuerst möchte ich ganz klar sagen
wir haben die 12 Euro Mindestlohn im
Wahlkampf nicht nur nicht nur propagiert
wir haben sie jetzt auch sehr
erfolgreich durchgesetzt und ich finde
das ein wichtigen Schritt und ein
wichtiges Signal auch wenn es jetzt
natürlich bei der steigenden Inflation
auch eine Euro hätte mehr sein können
und das ist schon ein erster wichtiger
Schritt in die Richtung das
Lohnabstandsgebot zu Hartz IV zu erhöhen
einfach um die Anreize zu schaffen es
wurde schon gesagt ist die Unternehmen
die Einrichtung die Suche Händeringen
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter und das
ist ein erster wichtiger Schritt
natürlich ist es auch das Problem es
wurde richtig gesagt dass wir auch noch
mal bei den Rentnerinnen und Rentnern
nachsteuern müssen wir sind jetzt aber
in der Situation dass die
entlastungspakete die wir mit dem
osterpaket geschnürt haben die über 30
Milliarden in den zwei Paketen auch
teilweise erst nach dem ersten Juli
anfangen zu wirken und da müssen wir
auch gucken wie bewirkt sich das auf aus
auf die Bevölkerung aber ich ich denke
wir werden um weitere Schritte auch
nicht darum kommen das wären zum
Beispiel wir wollen ja widersprechen
weil wir kommen von einem zehnjährigen
Aufschwung in der Zeit ist kein Geld
gespart worden ist munter ausgegeben
worden dann hatten wir ein Zweier
gepandemie wir haben einen riesigen
Schuldenberg aufgehäuft dann kommt jetzt
noch der Krieg das heißt wir haben in
den letzten beiden Jahren Bazooka ist ja
das beliebte Stichwort vom damaligen
Finanzminister Scholz noch also mit mit
viel Geld immer wieder Probleme über
tünzen so nur das geht nicht mehr so
weiter immer die Inflation kommt ja
nicht von irgendwoher die steigenden
Zinsen kommen nicht von irgendwoher wir
haben 200 Milliarden Euro Schulden und
der Schuldenberg wächst und wächst und
jetzt gibt es schon wieder
Verpflichtungen durch die Ukraine
für die Bundeswehr die sind jetzt als
Sondervermögen deklariert für uns
natürlich Etikettenschwindel ist eine
sonderverschuldung muss auch mal bezahlt
werden also jetzt ich glaube der der
Versuch der Regierung in den letzten
beiden corona-jahren jedes Problem
mit weiteren Geld zu überdecken der ist
jetzt am Ende man kann das nicht mehr so
weitermachen und wir haben ja nun auch
eine Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz
vereinbart und die muss eingehalten
werden der Versuch ist wieder eine neue
Notlage zu konstruieren um auch da
wieder rüber zu kommen wieder neue
Schulden zu machen dabei sind alte
Probleme noch nicht gelöst das Problem
der Demografie des steigenden Renten wir
haben über 100 Milliarden Euro
Bundeszuschuss zur Rente alleine etc pp
also das funktioniert am Ende gekommen
weiter ich weiß dass sie sich dazu
äußern wollen wird aber gerne Herrn Völz
noch kurz dazu hören bevor sie dann
wieder das Wort bekommen
weil es gab eine Ursache die Agenda 2010
und das fordern und fördern diese
Dualität hat maßgeblich dazu beigetragen
dass wir von der Massenarbeitslosigkeit
runtergekommen sind und ich sehe es
nicht eine einfach nur darauf hin dazu
weisen dass es möglicherweise ungerecht
ist oder dass die Entlohnung nach 12
Euro im Grunde immer noch nicht
ausreichend ist es ist leider so man
kann sich nicht von ökonomischen
Gesetzmäßigkeiten trennen es wird nach
Produktivität entlohnt und wenn die
Produktivität nicht gegeben ist durch
den Höhe des Lohnes dann wird es ul
positiv auch zur Arbeitslosigkeit führen
zu Entlassung zu Standortverlagerung und
das wird sicherlich kein Unternehmer
gerne tun jeder freut sich insbesondere
Mittelständler am Standort Deutschlands
wirtschaftlich Aktivitäten zu betreiben
seit Jahrzehnten schon seit Ende des
Zweiten
weltkriegeshen also zum Beispiel weil
beim beim Flughafen dass sie da nicht
mehr arbeiten weil sie zu wenig Geld
bekommen haben weil sie woanders mehr
bekommen also wie lösen sie denn das in
dieser Zusammenhang muss der Gesetzgeber
kreativ werden und der einen Weg wird ja
schon beschritten obwohl ich den erst
wenig untauglich halte sondern es gibt
andere Wege beispielsweise dadurch dass
für temporären zeitsatz an höherer Lohn
gezahlt wird und das dort dann andere
erhöht wird über die lohnebene das ist
sicherlich ein Weg den man gehen kann
und man müsste nicht notwendigerweise
auf ausländische Fachkräfte
zurückgreifen die jetzt sozusagen für
einen gewissen Zeitraum zu uns kommen
werden also dann doch höhere Löhne das
wäre dann sinnvoll für ein
glückmechanismus
davon trenne ich mich nicht Herr Walter
sie wollten gerade noch widersprechen
also
im Prinzip möchte ich jetzt zwei Sachen
kurz widersprechen einmal die 12 Euro
Mindestlohn das ist ja nicht so also ich
habe doch kein Unternehmen gehört dass
ich jetzt großartig beschwert hat dass
es 12 Euro Mindestlohn bezahlen muss
auch ganz viele spitzenverbinder haben
zwar Bedenken an angesprochen im
fachbearbeiterbereich wenn es dann
höhere Löhne gibt ja aber der 12 Euro
Mindestlohn ist jetzt kein Problem und
die Inflation es wird manchmal so getan
als ist die Inflation entstanden weil
die Leute einfach zu viel Geld hätten
und zu viel ausgeben dass die Inflation
entsteht er dadurch dass das Angebot
viel zu gering ist dass die Lieferketten
gestört sind dass die Schiffe in China
im Hafen liegen weil wieder
silberkorbit-politik betrieben wird
einfach die Lieferketten die
Seeschifffahrt hat monopolistische Züge
langsam angenommen und die Preise
vervielfachen sich zur Zeit das sind die
Inflationstreiber und nicht weil die
Leute zu viel Geld haben und zu viel
ausgeben
den Punkt ange wir brauchen das dann
irgendwann mal jetzt schluss ist Frau
Kostka wie sehen sie es denn wie sehr
muss der Staat sozusagen immer wieder ja
wenn es nicht mehr reicht einspringen
also erstmal möchte ich feststellen das
glaube ich unser Sozialstaat und auch
unser Wirtschaftssystem für solche
Krisensituationen ganz gut vorbereitet
ist also im Vergleich zu manch anderen
Ländern haben wir einfach gute
Voraussetzungen weil wir eben ein
Existenzminimum haben weil wir
gut ausgebauten Sozialstaat genau also
sonst hätten wir auch Corona nicht so
überstanden wie es passiert ist was
natürlich wichtig ist dass Härten
abgedeckt werden und wir haben einfach
bestimmte Bevölkerungsgruppen die jetzt
vor einem harten Winter stehen und die
unter Umständen das Risiko haben dass
sie die Wohnung verlieren zum Beispiel
weil sie sich Energiekosten nicht mehr
leisten können und sowas muss man
verhindern weil jede verlorene Wohnung
produziert wieder andere Nöte und
Probleme also das heißt wir müssen
einfach gucken was gibt es für Lösungen
und ich gebe Ihnen recht man kann nicht
alles mit Geld lösen sondern ein
wichtiger Punkt ist ganz klar Härten
abzudecken Menschen also kreative
Lösungen zu finden und es gibt zum
Beispiel ein ganz einfaches Instrument
von dem sehr viele profitieren können
also die steigenden Energiekosten sind
riesen Problem und wir haben als Caritas
bundesweit seit 2008 ein Projekt das
heißt Stromspar checkt da werden
Langzeitarbeitslose zu Energieberatern
ausgebildet die dann Familien und
Menschen mit Grundsicherung und Hartz IV
eben beraten wie sie Energie sparen
können das ist das davon profitierten
alle da fanden schon über 400.000
Hausbesuche statt fast eine Milliarde
Kilogramm CO2 wurde eingespart das ist
etwas was jetzt ganz konkret hilft viele
der Menschen finden anschließend eine
Stelle dann auch als Hausmeister oder
andere Tätigkeiten und so etwas würde
ich gerne flächendeckend ausrollen dazu
brauchen wir Überweisung vom Jobcenter
das ist ein wichtiger Punkt aber wenn
wir das also ich habe in hier in Berlin
50 Stellen davon sind 30 zurzeit nur be
über die Jobcenter einfach da nicht in
Dinge nicht hinterherkommen wir sollten
das Ausrollen weil das das hilft allen
und es sogar eine integrative Maßnahme
für den Arbeitsmarkt weil darüber
wirklich viele Menschen dann auch in den
ersten Arbeitsmarkt wiederkommen können
und so etwas das ist eine super Maßnahme
lasst uns das Ausrollen davon
profitieren alle und zum Schluss auch
noch das Klima Helfer ist wie sehr
welche kreativen Lösungen gibt es denn
von Unternehmen gerade wenn sie jetzt im
Moment auch durch die Pandemie und jetzt
auch noch durch die
Lieferschwierigkeiten durch den Ukraine
krieg ja Produktionsprobleme haben gibt
es da andere Möglichkeiten schauen die
Unternehmen sich um suchen die was
anderes die Unternehmen gerade die das
Mittelstandes sind extrem flexibel was
das Einstellen auf für neue
Gegebenheiten eingeht und wir versuchen
umzustellen die Produktion dahingehende
Güter die mit günstigeren Vorleistung zu
produzieren sind dann ein weiterer Weg
wenn es mehrere Standorte gibt den
Standort zu wählen der die günstigen
Produktionsbedingungen hat
mittelständische Unternehmen zeichnen
sich dadurch aus dem Gegensatz zu
Konzern dass im Wesentlichen sich auf
Deutschland konzentrieren und das sind
sehr sehr erfolgreich Konzerne haben
dort eine andere Vorgehensweise und eine
andere Möglichkeit ist natürlich auch
bestimmte Dinge auszusetzen wegzugeben
Teil dazulieferungen aus die verifiziert
zu Bedingungen aus anderen Ländern zu
bekommen europäischen Ländern und dann
durch günstige Kosten kalkulieren zu
können mit Preisen die dann den
Wettbewerbern etwas erleichtern
wie sehr denken Sie das ist in diesem
Herbst sozusagen uns noch mal richtig
einholt wenn die Gaspreise extrem
steigern steigen oder vielleicht auch
schon in der in der nächsten Woche
übernächsten Woche am 11 juli wenn
gazpromen die Leitungen die Pipeline
gewartet wird und die Angst ist dass wir
dann gar kein Gas mehr bekommen also was
was ist so das ja ein so ein schwieriges
Szenario naja dieses Worst Case Szenario
ab dem 11 bei anlässlich dieser Wartung
die dann wahrscheinlicher als als
Vorwand genommen wird um überhaupt kein
Gas mehr zu liefern das ist ja dann
Stufe 3 dieses Notfallplan was ist denn
der bundeswirtschaft zum klimaminister
ja schon angekündigt hat wenn ich ihn
richtig verstehe und sie haben mal seine
so zunehmenden Warnungen auch richtig
deute dann rückt das offenbar näher und
das machen sich die die Unternehmen ja
schon große Sorgen zu Recht weil
natürlich in Deutschland hat man noch
eine große Grundstoffindustrie viele
Industrieprodukte beruhen sozusagen auf
Gas sei es in der Produktion sei es auch
ein Produkt selber weil Gas wird
gebraucht man für eine chemischen
Industrie 90 Prozent der
Industrieprodukte beruhen auf diesen
Vorleistungen das heißt wenn die nicht
mehr produzieren können gibt es also
einen ketteneffekt ja und
dessen Folgen mag man sich nicht
ausmalen also vielleicht damit man
darauf reagieren kann ja gut es gibt ja
diese Vorbereitungen
die größten Gasverbraucher ermittelt die
200.000 Größen in Deutschland so und da
wird natürlich vorgegangen nach der
Frage wie wichtig es dann Produkt welche
in volkswirtschaftlichen Bedeutung hat
es auch mit dem Blick auf Lieferketten
für die Grundstoff Versorgung für alle
diese Dinge weil es eben gesagt hat und
dann wird halt abgeschichte das heißt
aber natürlich auch andere Unternehmen
bekommen dann vielleicht gar kein Gas
mehr das heißt die werden dann
stillgelegt und zum Beispiel eine Glas
eine Glashütte habe ich jetzt gelernt
wie kann man nicht stilllegen weil wenn
das Glas zusammen erkaltet dann ist ist
das kaputt ja also diese Beispiele gibt
es leider viele wie stellen Sie sich
darauf ein wenn ich nur darüber sprechen
was der Status Quo ist sondern
möglicherweise auf Lösungswege
aufzeichnen wie wir aus dieser
verfahrenen Situation besser rauskommen
und einen Weg ist unsere Ansicht nach
das Unternehmen unterstützt werden
sollten bei dem Transformationsprozess
hin zur Klimaneutralität und
erfolgreiche Bewältigung der
Klimaneutralität mit dem Ziel CO2
Gasemissionen maximal auf Null zu
reduzieren so dass dort Programme die
dort die Transmission unterstützen
würden
unterstützt werden sollten also
Produktion von Unternehmen
oder was meinen Sie mit Programmen die
Unterschied Programme wie ein
Transformation vor den Unternehmen
erleichtert diese Situation geistige zu
bewältigen und zukünftig selbst Energie
zu erzeugen Strom beispielsweise durch
erneuerbare Energien Photovoltaik aber
auch durch Windkraftanlagen worin die
Unternehmen selber investieren können
oder weil sie sagen das Finanzierung das
ist weil diese Volumina zu tragen sind
gigantisch hoch sind diese Prämien die
man zu zahlen lesen die
Investitionsvolumen so hoch sind müsste
eigentlich die Unterstützung des Status
stärker ausfallen Herr Walter wo sehen
sie da ihren Schwerpunkt ist es
wichtiger wenn Herr Völz sagt man muss
da die Unternehmen unterstützen ist das
ein Punkt wo sie sagen ja das wäre
eigentlich ja der erste Programmpunkt
weil das wird wieder Wachstum generieren
oder sagen Sie nein wir müssen dann doch
auf die Verbraucher schauen und die
müssen dann ja mehr Geld bekommen damit
sie ihre Gasrechnung bezahlen können
also für die Unternehmen ist es denke
ich ganz wichtig dass sie auch
Planungssicherheit haben dass sie wissen
in welche Energieform oder in welcher
Form der Energieerzeugung können wir
jetzt investieren viele Unternehmen sind
auch bereits schon zu investieren die
zögern allerdings noch was kommt jetzt
beim Sommerpaket noch mit raus wir
müssen als Regierung dafür sorgen dass
auch die planungshindernisse abgebaut
werden dass das alles beschleunigt wird
viele Unternehmen warten nur darauf dass
investieren können klar auch die
Bevölkerung muss unterstützt werden hier
gibt es auf der einen Seite Vorschläge
Steuern zu senken ich habe es bei mir
aber im Wahlkreis oder ein ganz vielen
ostdeutschen Wahlkreisen ist es so viele
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer sind
Pendler die verdienen nicht so viel dass
sie übermäßig Steuern bezahlen und durch
die Pendlerpauschale schon vieles zurück
kriegen das hat dann keinen Einfluss
drauf hier müssen wir
unter anderem ja das ist das Thema was
auch wichtig ist
die gerade die Mineralölkonzerne haben
sich hier auch ein Stück weit die
Taschen voll gemacht vor Kriegsbeginn
war immer so der Abstand zwischen Rohöl
und Super E5 bei 40 Cent ohne Steuern
jetzt ist er bei 60 Cent angekommen
da merkt man schon hier ist eine
Marge gewaltig gestiegen auch Frau
Kostka was wäre ihre Meinung ja einen
sinnvolles Handeln jetzt der Politik
weil es gibt so viele verschiedene
Vorschläge die da auf dem Tisch sind da
sind auch FDP und Grüne sich nicht immer
einig also was wäre so eine ganz
konkrete Maßnahme wäre auch die
Absenkung der Mehrwertsteuer zum
Beispiel für bestimmte Lebensmittel für
Grundnahrungsmittel das könnten wir uns
ganz gut vorstellen das hätte bestimmt
auch Effekte solche
gießkannenmaßnahmen wie mit dem
Tankrabatt halten wir für kritisch da
wird aus unserer Sicht viel Geld
verpulvert und geht vielleicht auch in
die falschen Hände
und dann gibt es glaube sich noch etwas
ganz Entscheidendes und zwar wir
brauchen so etwas wie ein common sense
jetzt für diese Zeit die bevorsteht es
gibt ja diese politischen Appelle schon
zu sparen oder so weiter aber klar ist
dass diese diese Situation in der wir
jetzt sind und vielleicht auch über den
Winter kommen das ist nur gemeinsam
bewältigt werden kann und da wünsche ich
mir eigentlich auch von allen
zivilgesellschaftlichen und politischen
Akteuren und natürlich auch den
Unternehmen zu sagen wir schaffen es nur
gemeinsam und der hat jeder seinen Part
und das Energiesparen des Einzelnen bis
hin eben was können Unternehmen leisten
aber auch wie können soziale Härten
vermieden werden und was wir schon
befürchten wenn die Preissteigerung
einfach ungefiltert so weiterlaufen dass
wir so etwas bekommen wie ein sozial
Tsunami das heißt erstmal ist es noch
gewisse Ruhe aber irgendwann kommt die
richtige Welle und die erwarten wir vor
allen Dingen wenn die Leute dann ihre
Nebenkostenabrechnungen bekommen und das
ist ein das ist auch sozialer
Sprengstoff und deswegen ist es glaube
ich wirklich gehört jetzt zu dieser ich
sag mal Winter Vorbereitung ich sage das
ganz ausdrücklich weil das wird
sicherlich die schwierige Zeit sein dass
man versucht auch über die einzelnen
Fraktionen hinaus gemeinsame Bilder zu
entwickeln also ich habe da viel von der
Ukraine gelernt die hat sich auf
schwierige Situationen gemeinsam
vorbereitet und ich meine wir es könnte
man ja sagen den Menschen geht es noch
ganz gut eigentlich solange man noch in
Urlaub reisen kann dann ärgert man sich
zwar über das Chaos aber dass man zwei
Stunden auf seinen Koffer ist jetzt
wartet ist jetzt ja keine existenzielle
Frage letztendlich also ist es so ein
Punkt wo sie sagen ja vielleicht weil
auf der anderen Seite sagt die Politik
ja wir müssen uns auf Entbehrungen
einstellen habe gesagt wir werden ärmer
werden werden wir das wirklich sind wir
das schon merkt man ein Bären wir haben
sehr vorhin von Frau Kost gehört manche
Menschen merken es aber eben noch
Menschen merken dass man wir haben sechs
Millionen Leute glaube ich die jetzt von
diesem Mindestlohn in diesem
geschiedenen profitieren das heißt es
sind sechs Millionen Menschen die für 12
Euro die Stunde arbeiten das ist auch
nicht so wahnsinnig viel und die merken
es natürlich zuerst sie haben die
Rentner erwähnt also es gibt schon eine
Menge Leute die das merken auf der
anderen Seite sind wir im Vergleich da
immer noch ein relativ reiches Land
natürlich werden manche Leute ein
Problem haben wir
insgehaltskostenabrechnung kommt aber
wenn da mal 3 oder 4 oder 500 Euro
fällig sind das bringt manchen Probleme
aber das ist jetzt für mich noch nicht
der Grund für den sozialzunami er muss
auch mal ein bisschen finde ich die
Kirche im Dorf lassen und wir haben
jetzt nach vielen vielen Jahren das
Aufschwungs jetzt eine schwierige
Situation die Pandemie ist mit sehr viel
Geld des Staates überbrückt worden wir
haben es eben gesagt es sind Milliarden
geflossen für die Wirtschaft für die
Arbeitnehmer für die Rentner für alle
hat ein großer Paket es wird wieder über
Sommerpaket gesprochen ich glaube man
muss einfach auch mal versuchen diesen
Herausforderungen sich zu stellen und
Ehrlichkeit oder Ehrlichkeit und auch
ein bisschen den Willen solche Situation
noch mal durchzustehen und nicht bei
jedem Problem gleich immer wieder zum
Start zu laufen in der Startseite
dass wir so ein commentsen brauchen wie
kriegt man den denn hingestellt wenn sie
auf der anderen Seite sagen also das mit
den 12 Euro ist mir eigentlich schon zu
viel wie kriegt man das hin natürlich in
bestimmten Bereichen der Wirtschaft
durchaus problematisch ich denke man die
Erntehelfer ob sie diejenige sind die in
Dithmarschen kohlstechen oder Lüneburger
Heide blaubeerpflücken da ist durchaus
ein Problem ich bin aber ein bisschen
füllen dann sozial Tsunami Worte solche
Worte prägen das Denken und
möglicherweise auch das Handeln ich
warne davor wir zahlen in Deutschland
ich glaube 30 Prozent sozialcoder mit
30% des Bruttoinlandsprodukts wird in
Deutschland für Sozialleistung
ausgegeben und sozialsundami verzerrt
meines Erachtens nach vollkommen die
Wahrnehmung ist es richtig durch die
aktuelle Situation werden viele Menschen
negativ betroffen es darf aber auch
nicht sein dass nur diejenigen
betrachtet werden die besonders stark
betroffen sind im sozialen Sektor
Unternehmen leiden unter den hohen
Steuern und Sozialabgaben wir haben
gerade in Erfahrung gebracht durch den
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach
dass die Kosten für den für die
Krankenkassen zusätzlich noch steigen
werden das heißt die 40 Prozent
gesamtsozialversicherungsbeitragssatz
wird Schritt überschritten werden und es
bleibt noch weniger Netto vom Brutto
übrig auch das ist ein Punkt da müsste
sich der Gesetzgeber dringend drum
kümmern es gibt eine Vielzahl von
Vorschlägen wie wir da im Einzelnen
Vorgehen
grundlegende Reformen beispielsweise in
allen zweigenen Sozialversicherung dort
gibt es erhebliche Möglichkeiten auf
Basis aber Angebote zu reduzieren und
alles zusätzlich ein bisschen
Eigenverantwortung getragen werden auch
dieser Bereich den gilt es nicht zu
vernachlässigen trotzdem wird noch
einmal ganz kurz den Nachfrage was ist
denn für sie ein gerechter Stundenlohn
für einen blaubeerpflücker
wenn sie sagen 12 Euro ist so viel der
Stundenlohn orientiert sich daran was
derjenige der den blauen Pflücker
einstellt am Markt erzielen kann für
seine Blaubeeren den blaubeerpflücker
bezahlen kann die gesamte Bürokratie die
damit verbunden ist den aus Osteuropa
hierher zu schaffen unterzubringen und
dann auch noch ein Deckungsbeitrag zur
erwirtschaften so dass sich für ihn das
ganze auch noch lohnt und er nicht auf
den Gedanken kommt im nächsten Jahr baue
ich keine Blaubeeren an dann kommen sie
aus Spanien aber im Summe können Sie
jetzt nicht nennen wir konkrete Summe
hängt von dem Einzelfall ab das hängt
von der Region ab in der derjenige der
die Bürger an Bord oder die Kohlköpfe
sticht ab okay
das Stichwort es geht ja darum die
sozialsunami zu verhindern und
dementsprechend ist es zu schauen was
kann man gemeinsam bewältigen und da hat
jeder seinen Partner natürlich hat auch
der einzelnen Prater bei und übrigens
die Sozialwirtschaft ist auch ein
erheblicher
unternehmerischer Faktor also ich habe
5000 Mitarbeitende dementsprechend ist
es sozusagen nicht also die die Fragen
die sich Unternehmen stellen die stellen
sich auch uns die steigenden
Energiekosten betreffen auch
Krankenhäuser betreffen auch alle
möglichen Bereiche im Sozialsektor also
es ist sozusagen man kann da nicht
einfach sagen da sind die Unternehmen da
ist irgendwie der soziale Sektor das ist
wesentlich differenzierter aus meiner
Sicht aber können sie verstehen das so
ein Wort wie sozialsunami was weg was
eigentlich eher kontraproduktiv ist es
zeigt glaube ich die Gefahr an das ist
wenn die Menschen verunsichert sind wenn
sie in sozial in existenzkrisen bekommen
dass das gesellschaftlicher Sprengstoff
ist und deswegen ist es wichtig im
Vorfeld zu gucken was was kann man tun
und wir sehen Handlungsmöglichkeiten im
Sinne der Prävention im Sinne auch
dessen dass das dass man versucht
gemeinsam Lösungen zu finden und
sicherlich nicht nur alles über Geld
weil wir könnten sie nicht durch die
Prägung solche Begriffe wie sozialsunami
die Verunsicherung noch zu schüren
anstatt sie etwas zu Senf gehen ich
frage sie in ihrer in ihrer Funktion ich
finde das schon also solche Worte in die
Welt zu setzen das muss man sich schon
überlegen auch von den Konsequenzen hier
ist er mit sich bringt es ist sicherlich
provokant aber es zeigt eben dass die
die Verunsicherung der Menschen sehr
sehr tief sitzt weil sie Angst haben
ihre Existenz zu verlieren und eben auch
viele vor der Frage stehen ob sie sich
ihre Lebensgrundlagen noch leisten
können und deswegen muss man an diese
Parameter dran und deswegen müssen auch
die verschiedenen Gruppen in den Blick
geraten und ich kann es nicht verstehen
warum die Bundes Berührung zum Beispiel
Rentnerinnen und Rentner nicht in den
Blick genommen hat das im energiegeld
ja und zwar auch relativ stark stärker
als die Arbeitseinkommen trotzdem ist es
bei
Rentnern mit kleinen
Renten die über der Grundsicherung sind
werden diesen diese steigenden
Energiekosten eben nicht finanzieren
können da gibt es sehr viel Unmut drüber
Herr Walter das es gibt sehr viel Unmut
dass diese energiegeld eben nicht für
Rentnerinnen und Rentner geht gibt es da
eine Möglichkeit dass man das noch
ändert
also wir haben natürlich auch die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner im Blick
da wird da wird es auch in Zukunft noch
Maßnahmen gehen aber zum energiegeld
genau kann ich jetzt nicht so viel sagen
wir hatten jetzt noch das Thema
Sozialabgaben es wäre natürlich ein
einfacher Mechanismus das kam heute von
den Grünen glaube ich wenn wir die
Beitragsbemessungsgrenze nach oben
schieben und die
sozialversicherungssätze ein bisschen
senken können dann haben natürlich auch
untere Einkommen mehr davon da geht
jeder Cent in den Konsum die großen
Einkommen mit großen Sparquoten wenn die
gerade in so ein Krisen behafteten
Zeiten zwei Euro mehr bezahlen für das
Gemeinwohl ist das durchaus verträglich
das sind die übliche Rhetoriker Walter
immer eine wenn Sie den den Betrag noch
höher setzen dann laden sie doch alle
ein aus der gesetzlichen
Krankenversicherung auszuschälen die
private zu wechseln das heißt sie haben
doch genau das Problem was diese
Versicherung heute schon haben dass
natürlich der Wille zu Solidarität
irgendwann an eine Grenze stößt meine
Krankenversicherung hat schon ein sehr
großes Solidarprinzip es kriegen ja alle
die gleiche Leistung raus und dann
setzen Krankenversicherung aber Sie
zahlen halt sehr sehr unterschiedliche
Beiträge und also in eine weitere
aufsetzung dieses Beitrages glaube ich
wenn eine Einladung für alle dann die
die GKV doch mal zu verlassen ich glaube
es kann nicht damit getan sein dass die
sogenannten Gutverdiener und das sind ja
Facharbeiter immer noch mehr zahlen
müssen gerade die das sind die Last Esel
unseres Sozialstaates die Leute die ein
bisschen mehr also Durchschnitt
verdienen und vielleicht
ja eher steuerlich entlasten als sie
noch weiter in irgendeiner Form
ranzunehmen für eine völlig verfehlte
Sozialpolitik die seit Jahren sich
scheut die notwendigen Reformen
anzufassen
ein anderer Vorschlag der diese Woche
auch kam war die Arbeitszeit zu erhöhen
auf 42 Stunden kam vom billi-präsidenten
raus vom Herr falls würde das helfen
das Ergebnis von Freiwilligen
Verhandlungen ist wenn sich Arbeitgeber
Arbeitnehmer einig sind dass das der Weg
ist den sie gemeinsam beschreiten wollen
dann ist es Sie eine vernünftige
Maßnahme ich möchte gerne den Begriff
den ich jetzt hoffentlich nicht als
prägungsbilden von den heutigen Abend
ansehen den Leistungsträger Exodus
entgegenhalten dann nämlich wenn immer
weniger Menschen bereit sind die würden
auf sich zu nehmen durch hohe
Sozialabgaben durch hohe Bürokratie
durch das Eingehen unternehmerischer
Wagnisse Risiken die Fahne streichen und
nicht bereit sind in Deutschland noch
unternehmerisch tagtäglich zu sein es
gibt von der Kreditanstalt für
Wiederaufbau die gründerquote die ist
seit Jahren rückläufig von im
altersgeordnete von 18 bis 63 100
Personen ist es gerade noch eine Person
die sich selbstständig macht dieser Wert
lag vor zehn zwölf Jahren noch bei vier
Personen und vor 20 30 Jahren bin ich
sicher da sagt dieser wird auch noch
deutlich höher
auch mit der Pandemie zu tun aber nicht
nur die Bürokratie ist mittlerweile auch
dass sie Umfragen zeigen dass in unserem
Verbandschuh 1 die
gesamtwirtschaftlichen Kosten der
bürokrative laufen sich auf über 50
Milliarden Euro Tendenz steigend und es
werden immer weiterer Bürokratie Monster
hinzugefügt und die jetzige
Bundesregierung Bilde leider keine
Ausnahme und von daher sehen wir der
Sache sehr skeptisch entgegen wenn
dieser Kurs der eingeschlagen worden ist
weiter fortgesetzt wird das merken Sie
sicherlich auch im Krankenhaus und
Pflegeeinrichtung die das die
Bürokratiemonster die nehmen jede Woche
zu und da ist auf jeden Fall
ein Sparpotenzial ich sehe auch die
Belastung mit steigenden Sozialabgaben
das ist natürlich ein Thema aber ich
glaube für die Unternehmen ist neben den
aktuellen Rahmenbedingungen sicherlich
das Fachkräfteproblem eins der größten
und nicht nur das Fachkräfteproblem
sondern das arbeitskräfteproblem und da
haben wir natürlich noch eine Ressource
die wir nicht nutzen und wo man relativ
schnell handeln könnte das sind
geflüchtete Menschen wir haben ja erlebt
dass jetzt über die Massen zu
schrumpfrichtlinie für Ukraine und
Ukrainer eine gute Lösung gefunden wurde
dass auch sofort in den Arbeitsmarkt
einsteigen können und wir haben extrem
viele Menschen mit fluchthintergrund die
mittlerweile auch gut ausgebildet sind
oder eben gut auch in Tätigkeiten sein
können die nicht eine Ausbildung
erfordern die einfach in einer
Warteschleife sind und wenn man da
wirklich durch zügige Verfahren die den
Menschen eine Perspektive geben würde
und der Ukraine wird vieles einfacher
gemacht als für andere Flüchtlinge und
da da gibt es große
arbeitskräftepotenziale und das fände
ich einer der entscheidenden Schritte
diesen Menschen eben die Chance zu geben
also da muss man einfach mal schauen
dass man da klug handelt und wir wissen
ja auch dass viele Unternehmen gerne die
Menschen auch anstellen das sinnvolle
als jetzt zum Beispiel konkret beim
Flughafen jetzt Arbeitskräfte aus der
Türkei absolut weil alleine bis die
Menschen da sind bis sie integriert also
nur bis das funktioniert das kann man
zwar alles machen aber das ist fern
vorbei und ja ja
bei den in den Flughafen Leuten gibt es
natürlich Sicherheitsanforderungen also
Stichwort Bürokratie die werden jetzt
mal kurz runtergesetzt also das führt
auch nicht zu viel aber wir haben doch
ein Problem zum Beispiel Stichwort
Chancen für zugewanderte oder für
Migranten ja aber da müssten wir die
Anforderungen die wir an diese Leute
stellen auch im Stichwort Ausbildung
radikal runterfahren meine wenn wenn es
schlecht ich glaube da mussten sich halt
je nachdem was es für ein Profis
überlegen also ich sag mal jemanden
Bäcker der im Brot backt was einem nicht
schmeckt der verkauft zwar nicht das
regelt sich über den Verkauf aber wenn
man zum Beispiel eine eine Solarzelle
auf dem Dach installiert das muss schon
richtig sein oder wenn man eine
Elektroleitung einbaut irgendwo da darf
man nachher also keinen Schaden erleiden
auch von besonders hohen Hindernissen
bei bestimmten Zeugnissen die da nicht
da sind und Leute eigentlich erkennen im
gegenseitiger Abschlüsse die Komplexität
auch von Prüfung in Berlin zum Beispiel
es gibt einen riesigen Mangel an an Gas
wasserinstallateuren das ist aber all
die Leute die am Ende auch diese
Energiewende bewerkstelligen sollen also
die zum Beispiel unsere solarthermin
einbauen sollen die Wärmepumpen die
Photovoltaikanlagen auf dem Dach es gibt
einfach zu wenig die Hälfte vom letzten
Jahrgang ist durchgefallen
wer den Prüfung von der Handwerkskammer
und
das ist natürlich auch eine Frage die
man sich stellen muss wie hoch sind die
Anforderungen wenn sogar schon ich sag
mal die meisten Deutschen Absolventen
durchführen wie will man da an einem
geflüchteten der vielleicht gerade ein
paar Brocken Deutschland in so einem
Arbeitsmarkt reinbringen also wenn man
da nicht wirklich umdenkt auch wegen der
Anforderung für dich wird es in Wahrheit
schwieriges Thema wie könnten sich
Unternehmen darauf ein oder wie stellen
Sie sich darauf ein auch gerade dann
Fachkräfte aus dem Ausland oder Menschen
die eben schon hier sind die geflüchtet
sind also wo ist ein Punkt wie gehen Sie
damit um
Flexibilität beispielsweise wenn man den
Pflegesektor denkt das Fachkräfte
Einwanderungsgesetz ist stark
verbesserungsbedürftig ist darf keine
Voraussetzung sein schon perfekte
deutsche Sprachkenntnisse zu haben um
auf dem deutschen Arbeitsmarkt im
Bereich der Pflege wirken zu dürfen es
muss möglich sein diese Sprachkenntnisse
sozusagen Training on the Job hier zu
erwerben
und diese Voraussetzungen sollte meines
Erachtens nach gestrichen werden also
gibt es den ein oder anderen Punkt wo
man erfolgreich an der Gesetz
bestehenden Gesetzeslage herumoperieren
kann so dass das Anwenden in der Praxis
einfacher wird und diese Probleme auch
weniger stark von Bedeutung sind ich
möchte aber auf einen Punkt
weiterhinweise es muss in erster Linie
uns darum gehen dass hiesige
Arbeitskräftepotenzial zu mobilisieren
berufstätige Frauen Qualifizierung
Weiterbildung oder aber auch was
Möglichkeiten angeht dass die
Zurückführung
ganz unser zutrauen und wäre es nicht
schaffen aber Zuwendung alleine wird
nicht ausreichend auch da gibt es
diverse Studien darüber 400.000 werden
eigentlich notwendig Jahr für Jahr muss
man aber wissen 40.000 verlassen
Deutschland auch jedes Jahr so heißt
nicht 400.000 werden auch gar nicht
ausreichen und dieses Problem lässt sich
sicherlich nicht alleine durch
Zuwanderung lösen wir müssen versuchen
alles aus dem heimischen Markt
herauszuholen und das Resonanz
gigantische haben noch eine Vielzahl von
Personen jährlich Schulen nicht
abschließend beim Abschluss die ihre
Ausbildung nicht zu Ende machen Energie
im Kantischen Möglichkeit durch verbess
in der Unterbringung von Kindern
tagsüber Frauen zu ermöglichen auch
berufstätig zu sein das
Ehegattensplitting sollte ja eingeführt
werden das Familiensplitting sollte
dafür kommen als also
dafür eingeführt werden also hier gibt
es Reformbedarf wird auch regelmäßig von
der Europäischen Union angemerkt dass
hier Deutschland noch erheblichen
Nachholbedarf hat Herr wollte wenn Sie
das hören was Herr fölster
sagt den Punkten gehen sie da mit wo
sehen sie eine Möglichkeit schnell
diesen Personalmangel zu beheben
wie gesagt es gibt ein großes Potenzial
gerade
angeflüchteten die schon hier sind
teilweise sind die auch gut ausgebildet
da muss der Zugang zum Arbeitsmarkt ganz
dringend erleichtert werden wir wir
brauchen außerdem
funktionierendes
fachkräftezuwanderungsgesetz ist es
natürlich auch richtig das war aus der
heimischen Bevölkerung
alle Möglichkeiten ausschöpfen dort so
viele Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
zu gewinnen wie möglich wir machen sie
das jetzt schnell aber wie was können
Sie jetzt umsetzen
woran würden sie sich da oder sollte
sich die SPD da messen lassen
also ich würde mir wünschen wenn wir das
die vielen bürokratischen Hirten die es
gibt abschaffen und vereinfachen
das soll natürlich nicht auf den
Sicherheitsaspekt gehen aber es gibt
ganz viele Bereiche wo wir denke ich
schnell auch geflüchtete einstellen
können es gibt ein ganz einfaches Mittel
was man machen könnte dazu müsste man
noch nicht mal 1000 Gesetze verändern
sondern eine Erfahrung ist das gerade
Menschen die also jetzt keine
strukturellen vermittlungshindernisse
haben wie zum Beispiel fehlende
Kinderbetreuung oder sowas sondern
vielleicht einfach in ihrer
Erwerbsbiografie bestimmte Lücken haben
oder Suchterkrankungen haben oder andere
Themen die ihnen es schwierig machen auf
dem ersten Arbeitsmarkt zu bestehen eine
ganz
gute Sache ist dass wenn man die
Menschen in den ersten Arbeitsmarkt
integriert dann ist eine ganz typische
Erfahrung dass es wichtig ist dass die
Unternehmen sozialpädagogisch
Unterstützung haben weil wenn Krisen
entstehen wir haben auch ganz viele
junge Menschen die Ausbildung abbrechen
riesen Thema und da ist ganz natürlich
das dann dass sie eben mit bestimmten
Dingen nicht zurechtkommen und das dann
sozialpädagogische Interventionen helfen
können dazu gibt es auch schon Studien
oder so weiter also die Begleitung von
Unternehmen wenn sie Mensch solche
Menschen anstellen oder wenn sie eben
auch sozusagen nicht den ideal
Jugendlichen in der in der Ausbildung
haben das wären ganz einfache Maßnahmen
die sich auch praktisch wo man gute
Erfolge haben kann aber das heißt eben
da muss man natürlich auch was für in
die Hand nehmen aber im Verhältnis kann
man deutlich zeigen dass daraus oft sehr
gute Arbeitnehmer werden die auch eine
lange Betriebsbindung haben also muss
die Menschen begleitet hat das sind ja
auch Erfahrungen die man mit
geflüchteten gemacht hat die 2015
hierher kam die die gut begleitet wurden
konnten auch gut integriert werden jetzt
haben wir schon mehrmals über diese
konzertierte Aktion gesprochen am 4.7
hat Bundeskanzler Scholz ja angekündigt
da sollen alle zusammenkommen
Gewerkschaften Arbeitgeber Experten Herr
kaufert was erwarten sie denn diese
Einmalzahlung die Scholz angekündigt hat
teilweise auch schon ein bisschen
zurückgenommen weil da so viel Kritik
dran gab gibt es ein Punkt wo sie sagen
das wäre jetzt ein gutes Signal da
nächste Woche
oder die ist die Aktion an sich schon
ein Signal was hilft die Aktion ist
sicherlich ein Signal
wenngleich ist eben auch nur eine
begrenzte Wirkung hat wenn uns gesagt
die tarifgebundenen werden davon
profitieren ein großer Teil der anderen
nicht die Rentner eben auch nicht aber
doch wir müssen auch weg davon wegkommen
nach dem Motto wir diskutieren diese
eine Maßnahme die alles schafft die gibt
es nämlich nicht sondern es ist immer
wichtig ein bisschen was zu versuchen
und insofern ist das sicherlich ein
Versuch wert es hängt aber natürlich
davon ab ob Gewerkschaften und
Arbeitgeber bei der Sache mitmachen so
denn die haben das wir versucht die Zeit
am Ende in der Hand wir haben
Tarifautonomie und wenn die sich am Ende
dagegen sperren dann wird das nichts
wäre vielleicht manchmal besser die
Politik würde sich dann mehr raushalten
na ich weiß nicht also dieser Impuls ist
ja jetzt nicht schlecht also die Idee
vielleicht auf diese Weise die Lohn
Preisspirale etwas zu bremsen wenn es
funktioniert ist ja nicht grundsätzlich
verkehrt aber wir wollen erstmal
abfangen wie sich die Inflation dann
auch wirklich entwickelt also jetzt 7,6
Prozent
zu sagen aber wir reden ja dann über den
Herbst für dieses konzertierte Aktion da
ist man auch wieder ein paar Monate
klüger also ist es überhaupt notwendig
verfestigt sich Inflation und so weiter
und so weiter wenn das so ist und man an
Übereinkommen findet zwischen den
Tarifparteien dann finde ich kann man
das durchaus versuchen aber die
Entscheidung treffen natürlich nach wie
vor die Gewerkschaften die Arbeitgeber
und nicht die Politik weil es gibt ein
Punkt wo sie auf was sie hoffen da bei
dieser ich hoffe dass der Staat sich auf
seine originären Aufgaben beschränkt
dass er die Schuldenbremse weiter anhält
unterstützen da ein ganz sehr den
Finanzminister Lindner das Steuern und
Abgaben reduziert werden und das sich
Gedanken darüber gemacht wird wo man
durch Strukturreformen Hand anlegen kann
an den wahren Belastungen und sich nicht
auf Nebenkriegsschauplätze verlagert
okay vielen Dank Herr Völz Frau Kostka
und Herr Walter zugeschaltet und vielen
dank ihnen fürs Interesse wir haben
zumindest versucht hier schon mal
miteinander darüber zu sprechen morgen
reden wir über den NATO-Gipfel in Madrid
Fragen mehr Waffen mehr Mitglieder mehr
Stärke jetzt geht es aber weiter Phoenix
der Tag mit Thomas Bade bis dann tschüss